une bonne nouvelle pour les industriels
landais un iut de l'agroalimentaire
verra le jour dès la rentrée prochaine
un projet mise en route depuis quelques
mois qui s'est rapidement concrétisé cet
institut universitaire permettra à de
nombreux landais de pouvoir étudier tout
en restant dans leur département nous
sommes aux apps dans les landes à
recevoir des instituts
comme celui ils ont nous parlons en
matière d'agro alimentaire peut être
aussi je l'espère quelque chose en
matière d'ingénierie du bois et je suis
heureux de réunion qui a eu aujourd'hui
parce que les professionnels étaient là
les chambres consulaires et puis les
élus le rectorat les élus et industriels
locaux ont donc défini la spécificité de
cet iut tout en tenant compte de son
environnement et de la complémentarité
avec les établissements existants à
mont-de-marsan on a choisi
l'enseignement de la qualité il formera
donc des cas les siens reste à savoir
maintenant ce qu'en pensent les
industriels landes et de
l'agroalimentaire et la création de
l'iut répondent parfaitement à la
nécessité d'encadrer d'exploiter avec
des techniciens pointus
nos techniques et nos produits dans
l'agroalimentaire notamment en mettant
en oeuvre une politique de qualité et de
certification qui est je pense
envisageable nécessaires à l'horizon
2020 trois enseignants seront recrutés
dans les semaines à venir et pour
l'année universitaire 92 des bâtiments
devront être construits pour accueillir
cet établissement mais aucun si pour
l'instant n'a été officiellement retenu
en attendant la prochaine rentrée se
déroulera dans les locaux de l'école
normale de mont de marsan